ähm es ist verführerisch Corona ist
vorbei die corona-pandemie ist vorbei es
ist verführerisch wir können sagen wir
haben es hinter uns wir vergessen alles
und wir lassen das ähm das ist
gefährlich weil wir da nicht lernen wir
lernen da nicht was falsch gelaufen ist
und wenn man das jetzt mal sich anguckt
Bundesverfassungsgericht und Justiz
allgemein wenn man sich die Frage
gestellt hatte Justiz hat er Rechtsstaat
funktioniert während der corona-krise
dann würde ich ganz klar sagen nein es
ist tatsächlich es ist eine es ist nicht
opportun des Bundesverfassungsgericht zu
kritisieren in Deutschland ich tue es
aber das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat
seine Aufgabe nicht wahrgenommen die
Aufgabe des bundesverfassungsrechts ist
ähm es musste Hüter der Verfassung sein
es muss aufpassen dass es muss aufpassen
dass alle staatlichen Institutionen sich
an die Verfassung halten das ist auch
nicht zum Spaß das hatten Sinn und Zweck
es geht darum die Freiheit der Bürger zu
schützen die Freiheit vor dem
übergriffigen Staat zu schützen und das
hat das bundesverfassungsrecht nicht
gemacht es gab unzählige es gab
unzählige Verfassungsbeschwerden andere
Verfahren vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht den ganz großen
Teil der Beschwerden hat das
bundesverfassungsrecht gar nicht
angenommen
einige Beschwerden die Sie entschieden
haben haben sie einfach mit
floskelhaften Begründungen einfach
abgelehnt und die große Entscheidung zum
zur bundesnotbremse war eigentlich ein
abnickender Politik von der Regierung
Merkel also das Bundesverfassungsgericht
hat nirgendwo eingegriffen wir hatten
Ausgangssperren wir hatten harte
lockdowns werden wochenlange
Schulschließungen z.B wir hatten alles
möglich wir hatten die härtesten
Eingriffe in Grundrechte die wir in der
ganzen die wir in der ganzen Geschichte
der Bundesrepublik hatten und das
bundesverfassungsrecht macht nichts das
Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt ja okay
Stempel drauf war alles in Ordnung das
müssen wir aufarbeiten hat sich aus
ihrer sich das Bundesverfassungsgericht
zu sehr von der Politik vereinnahmen
lassen in der coronazeit ganz eindeutig
ganz eindeutig das hat das
bundesverfassungsrecht hat seine Rolle
verpasst die Rolle ist wir müssen die
Politik und die anderen staatlichen
Institutionen kritisch kontrollieren das
haben die nicht gemacht die sagten naja
wir müssen jetzt den Staat unterstützen
wir kämpfen gegen die Pandemie und sonst
was und wir müssen alle zusammenhalten
und das machen wir dann auch indem wir
alles abnicken und das ist eben das hat
die die Rolle des
bundesverfahrensgerichts hat in der
Krise nicht funktioniert und das ist ein
Problem und da müssen wir darüber reden
was am System was am Justizsystem was am
verfassungsrechtssystem nicht
funktioniert hat was hätte man aus ihrer
sich sofort beispielsweise im Eifer
fahren stoppen müssen wo sind die Punkte
wo sie sagen da liegt für mich das
Größte versagen wir haben ein paar Dinge
jetzt gerade angesprochen wir erinnern
uns da an Szenen Menschen dann draußen
Sport gemacht oder Kinder waren beim
Rodeln die Maske nicht getragen da gab
es Bußgelder was sind die Punkte wo sie
sagen wer hätte sofort reagiert werden
müssen das sind genau die Punkte die
Gerichte also nicht nur das
bundesverfassungsrecht sondern auch die
anderen Gerichte die unteren Instanzen
die haben sozusagen nur auf einige
Experten gehört die bestimmte
Erkenntnisse vorgetragen haben und dann
haben sie gesagt okay vor diesem
Hintergrund es ist ja ansteckend also
wird nicht brodelt es ist sehr es ist
sehr ansteckend also dürfen wir uns im
Park nicht aufhalten wir dürfen nicht
auf der Bank sitzen und Bücher lesen es
gibt es gab hunderte von diesen kleinen
Geschichten hätten die Gerichte einfach
sich genauer anschauen müssen was ist
eigentlich die Erkenntnislage es ist ja
nicht so wie jetzt behauptet wird dass
man damals alles nicht wusste das stimmt
nicht man hat nur manche Erkenntnisse
der Wissenschaft die einem nicht
gefallen haben die nicht zu Mainstream
gepasst haben diese Erkenntnisse hat man
ignoriert und da hätten die Gerichte
gleich von Anfang an das machen müssen
was sie eigentlich immer machen nämlich
kontrollieren hard kontrollieren genau
hinschaut was haben sie nicht gemacht
und in letzter Zeit es ist ja es fängt
oben an es fängt oben an das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat die
Richtung vorgegeben und die Richtung war
wir nicken alles ab und wir unterstützen
die Regierung bei ihrem Kampf gegen die
schlimme Pandemie damit will ich nicht
die Pandemie kleinreden aber es kann
nicht sein dass die Grundrechte und die
Freiheiten in der Krise nichts mehr
zählen die Verfassung und die Freiheiten
gelten immer auch in der Krise was sind
ihre Konsequenzen welche müssen gezogen
werden man sieht ja jetzt auch in der
Politik da kommen erste Eingeständnisse
da kommen kommt eine kritische
Auseinandersetzung man hat das Gefühl
die Aufarbeitung ist in kleinen Baby
steps im Gange was welche Forderungen
formulieren Sie konkret was muss
passieren diese diese Aufarbeitung muss
richtig anfangen was wir jetzt sehen ist
ist mehr oder weniger auch dass das so
Nebelkerze geworfen werden so nach dem
Motto naja es war nicht alles in Ordnung
wir müssen uns viel verzeihen und damit
ist Schluss und jetzt gucken wir in die
Zukunft jetzt gucken uns andere Problem
an wir müssen einfach ganz genau
hingucken ganz genau die Fragen stellen
an welcher Stelle ist was schiefgelaufen
und wie kriegen wir das hin wie wie
kriegen wir sichergestellt dass die
Justiz in Zukunft wenn es wieder eine
Krise gibt die Freiheit der Bürger
schützt und nicht das macht was ich
jetzt gemacht hat ist wenn nicht so tief
greifen dass wir sagen sind die Wahl
Entscheidungen zum
bundesverfassungsrecht da denn wirklich
haben sie denen das Niveau wie früher
ich habe bei den Eindruck es werden
immer mehr nur Parteigänger gewählt die
sozusagen polit
sozusagen mit der Bund mit der
Bundespolitik harmonieren ich glaube das
ich habe das am klimaschutzurteil
gesehen nicht da war ja auch ein Vorgang
der ist katastrophal da hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht einfach die
Meinung der Bundesregierung
durchgewunken und das liegt natürlich
daran dass früher die Politik sich auch
erlaubt hat
eigene Köpfe freie Köpfe unabhängige
Köpfe zu
Verfassungsrichter zu machen heute habe
ich den Eindruck das ist eine
parteipolitische Veranstaltung
diejenigen die am parteivorsten sind die
kommen ins Bundesverfassung ja und
insgesamt ist es auch glaube ich so
rechtlich gesehen sind die
Verfassungsrecht ja völlig unabhängig
kann oder was aber sie brauchen auch
psychologisch oder sie brauchen auch das
Rückgrat um diese um diese
Unabhängigkeit auch auszuleben es nützt
nichts wenn sie sich selber im Kopf
beschränkt und sagen okay okay ich mache
jetzt was die Regierung und das ist
wahrscheinlich das was sie meinen mit
unabhängigen Köpfen früher und starken
Persönlichkeiten die sagen okay auch in
der Krise fallen wir die Regierung jetzt
mal ins in den Armen weil wir haben die
wir haben die Freiheiten im Kopf und sie
haben völlig recht vielleicht muss man
oder muss man das Verfahren ändern mit
dem die Richter und Richterin am
Bundesverfassungsgericht bestimmt werden
warum müssen wir das so im Hintertürchen
im hinterkämmerchen machen zum Beispiel
das ist in Amerika finde ich persönlich
jetzt viel besser da werden die Richter
drei Tage lang gegrillt vom Parlament
und die werden durchleuchten da weiß man
genau welche Person kommt bei uns ist
das so dann kommt ein Name in die
Öffentlichkeit kein Mensch vorher gehört
wir wissen gar nicht wer das ist und die
Aufarbeitung in den USA man hat den
Eindruck läuft auch schneller voran
Untersuchungsausschuss gibt es dort
bereits haben Sie den Eindruck da tut
sich mehr absolut ich meine das ist
nochmal ein Beispiel ist diese haben es
gesehen dass bei der Pandemie bei der
corona-krise war die ähm bloß Dates die
eben von den Demokraten erklärt worden
sind da gab es diese
spartanische Maßnahmen die wollte man
überall durchsetzen und bei den Red
States auch Florida Texas hat man die
Pandemie andere anders behalten
behandelt es gab es nicht diese absolute
Einschränkungen der Wirtschaft in der in
den Schulen und Aussperrungen in Strafen
und so weiter und jetzt hat sich das
bewährt übrigens der Santis deswegen ist
er im Moment so populär in den USA weil
eben diesen wahnsinnig gemacht hat er
hat es war eine der die Meinung
vertreten hat das so gelassen und
übrigens der Trump war auch derjenige
der gesagt hat piano Piano langsam wir
werden damit fertig sein was immer über
den Kopf gekostet hat und das hat ihn
Kopf gekostet erstens und zweitens eine
Woche nach den Wahlen kam ist der
falschen Tag mit der Impfung aus weil es
vorher hieß er war um 5 Jahre und so
weiter und so fort gibt's keine Impfung
und ähm so viel auch zu der Manipulation
der Wahlen also es war auch ein ein
Faktor den ich hier nur erwähnen wollte
abgesehen von ihren Freunden aus New
York
timeswork mal zu oder ist sie auch
Verwaltung
spritzen lassen
gefragt er hat gefragt
aber jetzt nicht New York Times aber die
New York Times hat darüber berichtet und
nicht nur die es gibt einem Mann der
heißt Leonard Leo ganz wichtiger Mann
der hat mehr oder weniger Gerichte
vorgefiltert das wurde nicht in den
Herings bestimmt sondern da gibt's
Organisation die heißt Seite die wurde
ja vor zehn Jahren gegründet und die
werden ausgesucht bei bestimmten Themen
ob sie eben dafür sind dass es möglichst
wenig Regulierung gibt und mit Leben
weniger Steuern ja aber eben auch in der
Abtreibungsfrage da gab es ja ein
abtreibungsurteil im Jahre 73 Robbie
Wade das ein sehr liberales
Abtreibungsrecht etabliert werden es
wird aber öffentlich im Parlament
darüber diskutiert die werden bei uns ja
auch vorgefiltert die die Kandidaten
aber das machen 12 Leute aus dem
Bundestag das dieses vorfiltern ist ja
klar das passiert natürlich
darüber diskutiert Herr pramel ganz
großer Unterschied in der Treppe soweit
werden da werden wir schon Schritt
weiter ja
unterstützen in USA nämlich genau diese
abtreibungsurteil das Gericht hat nur
entschieden ob das ist die Sache des
obersten und das nicht verstehst gegen
die Verfassung die Verfassung das ist da
haben sie richtig angesprochen das ist
das oberste gut das die außenrichter
verteidigen wollen und die Risse haben
nur gesagt das war nicht richtig damals
das hat das steht nicht in der
Verfassung das Abtreibung
legal ist sondern das soll die
Parlamente letzten Endes die Bundes
Länder entscheiden ob es richtig ist
oder nicht ich wollte aber ganz was
anderes sagen wenn ich das vielleicht
aber ich bin ja gar nicht dazu gekommen
dem Punkt Ihre Frage zu beantworten es
geht nämlich darum dass bei solchen
Fragen Organisationen aussuchen
federalist zur Seite der der Leonard leo
hat mit Trampeltier gemacht wenn du als
Präsident nur von dieser Liste und diese
Liste ist bestätigt das hat mir Leonard
leer selber bestätigt zwei Dutzend
Richter wenn du nur von dieser Liste
nimmst hast du die Unterstützung der
christlichen ich glaube ich muss einem
Republikaner nicht aber ohne
Unterstützung wieder christliche Problem
wenn das so weitergeht dass unser
Bundesverfassungsgericht eigentlich nur
noch das abbildet was dem politischen
Mainstream von ihm erwartet wird dann
rüttelt das an den Grundfesten unseren
Demokratie das habe ich mein Leben lang
anders erlebt von allen anderen von
verfassungspräsidenten da hatte ich
immer das Gefühl der schützt mich dieses
Gericht schützt mich vor den Übergriffen
des Staates ja und das Gefühl haben die
Bürger nicht mehr und das ist ganz ganz
gefährlich sich auch so Punkt
Mikrofon ausgefallen ich habe auf jeden
Fall hier sowas flüssig bei mir liegen
ähm sagen Sie uns einmal welche
Konsequenzen fordern sie denn jetzt ganz
konkret werden das jetzt in der Politik
gesehen wir haben auch viele hier in der
Sendung sitzen die sagen die
Aufarbeitung muss so weit gehen dass
auch Politiker mal abdanken wir haben
jetzt neues Szenarien entworfen wie mehr
Transparenz geschaffen werden kann
beispielsweise was fordern Sie konkret
also ich fordere tatsächlich die
Aufarbeitung ich fordere auch ähm es
muss parlamentarisch untersucht werden
z.B muss auch ein parlamentarische
Untersuchungsausschuss geben der der wir
einfach mal erklärt was ist da
eigentlich gemacht worden und wir ich
fordere auch dass man tatsächlich auch
das Bundesverfassungsgericht in den
Blick nimmt und überlegt was ist da
eigentlich passiert wir können nicht
sagen naja das ist so in Deutschland so
ein bisschen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht ist heilig das
kritisieren wir gar nicht das geht so
nicht und wir müssen tatsächlich auch
eine Ebene tiefer Graben
das ist das was sie gerade gesagt haben
oder was sie gerade gesagt haben dass
man einfach überlegen muss welche
Schrauben müsste man im System
vielleicht verändern z.B muss man dafür
sorgen dass andere Menschen Richterinnen
und Richter werden zum Beispiel wie kann
man da was machen das wären so das wären
so die Idee es gibt verschiedene Ebenen
auf denen man arbeiten muss würden sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie